so our first speaker is going to be free
so fun falling oven Franco data-driven
on about understanding attack community
through notebooks thank you oh well I
can hear myself that's cool hope you can
hear me too little right in the back
awesome so um welcome everybody thank
you for for coming this morning I'll be
delivering a talk to you about
understanding the tech community through
notebooks obviously it has to be through
notebooks right this is my data it
couldn't be otherwise but what I'm what
I'm really about to tell you about is
it's basically my let's say background
projects you have a lot of work you lot
of things to do and there's always this
one thing if you kind of get back to
every every other week or so for maybe a
couple of hours and then at some point
these things kind of get out of hand and
that's exactly what happened here and by
now it's actually resulted in a quite a
nice little product that I'll show you
how we create that so this is basically
a notebook at the base exploration of
meetup com so who here knows about meet
up okay so maybe the other way around
who has never been to a medium before
all right let me explain you a little
bit about that before that about this
talk so this is basically a list of
tools that might be useful for you
number of packages number of frameworks
the number of ways of doing things and
this is also a exploratory analysis of
local tech communities through meetup
com but me I'm the CTO for god it's
driven I think we're actually kind of
responsible for having this event in
Amsterdam in the first place at some
point somebody went to London and came
back and the next morning told me hi
freezer we're doing PI data in Amsterdam
okay so here we are yeah that's my
github profile picture freeze also a
very popular brand of I think
dairy products for infants or something
i'm on twitter upset k that should be
easy to remember i'm on github as well
and too much stuff there and also forgot
it's driven apart from the ctrl i'm
basically the chief meetup organizer so
here in Amsterdam I organized the Hadoop
user group and I organized a or
co-organized meet up on apply machine
learning together with somebody who is
in the academic world and also I'm
partly responsible for the Amsterdam
apache spark meda so I have a keen
interest in meetups and as do many
people so what is the meetup basically
according to the good people of meetup
themselves it is the world's largest
network of local groups and making it
easy to organize local events where
people get together and the mission
there is to basically to revitalize the
local community and help people around
the world self-organized so that means
that people you know people get together
and through through an online meeting
platform where they make arrangements
from meeting in the offline real world
and do things like you know build houses
or clean up the neighborhood or go
knitting in the park and lots of yoga I
suppose as well so that's that's really
what meetup is about getting together in
the real world so if you look at meet up
in general it's it's an event based
social network it focuses on events
which are organized by by groups so
every meetup event belongs to a meetup
group and those groups of members and
the groups are discussing particular
topics that they inherently care about
like yoga or self-help or I don't know
apache spark right so that's the idea
but there's a couple of things that we
kind of also used me that will come for
and I think primarily my prior about
this audience would be the you are
pretty much familiar with the
Mead of specialization in there so
that's that's kind of single evening
many conferences and you get usually
free access and also look pizza and beer
for free have kind of become a commodity
in tech centers because you can just go
anywhere every every evening of the week
so for us meetups actually look a lot
like this right after work we go in dark
rooms and we have lots of pizza and
perhaps a couple of beers and we talk
about work again which is interesting
enough and the funny thing is actually
that's what we use me up for the most
because if you look at the number of
groups there are for each particular
category the meetup has then you see
these two spikes in that distribution so
the one on the left the right one is the
category of business meetups and the
really big one on the right there is the
category of tech or technology meetups
so that means if you look if you run
into somebody who knows about meetups
then knowing nothing else the likelihood
of them being in tech meetups is by far
the greatest there's 36 I think or so
categories but in the end in reality the
majority of meetup activity is just tech
I think that's good for us if nothing
else probably keeps the platform running
as well and it also inspires a lot of
good intentions with people so one of
the things that happens a lot is people
get carried away in their enthusiasts
amazed they say you know what we'll
start a meetup group and then kind of
slack off and never really organize any
events in there but by the way this is
just for Amsterdam and the same here
this is just but the the Amsterdam made
of community did this particular
behavior of starting a group and then
never organizing the event is actually
twelve percent of all tech meetups so
you know about one in ten of us has just
the good intentions and that's it now
obviously meet up as a platform is
growing pretty rapidly right so if you
look at the number of meetups over time
exist right here announce them and this
is just tech meetups then you can
imagine well twelve percent of the
meetups never really organized anything
but that could be because they're just
brand new right most of the meetups will
be a recent because the platform is
growing so rapidly but then if you look
into it a little bit and this is a bit
of a weird plot because the bidding
isn't uniform but this is basically the
histogram of the age in days of meetup
groups that never organized anything so
you can see right here there's about 12
meetups they were created in in the say
the last week at the time of collecting
these data that never did anything and I
think they are excused right you're
still getting your group together you're
working on things but then there's 35
meetups that were created between a week
and a month ago that never did anything
as well and then there's this entire
group here which is a year and another
year so those are groups that are well
over a year old and never really did
anything but it turns out there's other
uses as well so many many people in
let's say the evangelism business have
learned that meetup has a quite nicely
working recommender system that will
send you emails off about anything you
put in there as long as you check the
right topics that are supposedly
interesting to your meetup and this is
two and a half percent of all tech
meetups being just an announcement for
something else and not actually being an
event right there on meetup so maybe
they should work on that a little bit so
that's nice a couple of things we
learned about meet up so a question now
is how do we know all of this right well
obviously I didn't go on to meetup com
and click around to the side copy
pasting all of this stuff into excel so
meetup has an API that you can quite
liberally use to grab a substantial
amount of data from them it's there on
the on website it's very well documented
it gives you a complete view everything
that happens on the platform as long as
remember yourself and also it's
reasonably be generous when it comes to
rate limiting and it does the proper
implementation of rest this is an
example request we're basically getting
everything in category 34 which is tech
in country Netherlands city Amsterdam
we're looking for three results a page
and we only want to see the names and
the organizers name of meetup groups so
this HTTP comment is coming from
something called HTTP I you should
really get that if you ever do command
line rest calls it's so much easier than
then crow so which get out of it is
obviously response headers that will
have some some some rate limiting
information as well and then
subsequently you get a bunch of Jason
showing a metadata so that says there i
have three results but then also i have
897 results in total which is if i go to
the next page next place the next place
and so on you get all that and then
finally 30 actual jason body of the
results as well so that's nice now let's
look at what we're up to basically what
i wanted to do is get a feeling for the
tech community at large and i figured it
probably is a good idea to start with
the more interesting technology centers
that are out there in terms of software
engineering so me being from amsterdam i
put that first I think that's the
natural tendency for people from
Amsterdam and then I figured Berlin
London New York Chicago and San
Francisco should be nice as well
actually I didn't do Chicago initially
but I did at some point I wanted more
English language content to to Train
particular models so we look for all of
the groups within a hundred-mile radius
of these cities and then meet up will
basically give a whole lot of stuff so I
scheduled a little scrape
DeRozan Python 2 to go through the API
and get all the information on the
group's the events the members the RSVPs
for the people that actually express
that they're coming to an event the
longest of these jobs takes about 19
hours to run which is for San Francisco
understandably and I scheduled this with
Jenkins is anybody not know what Jenkins
is alright so Jenkins is technically a
built server however you can nicely
abuse it as a scheduler because it will
run your jobs on a schedule and then
also capture the outputs and it can send
you emails if things fail so this is my
Jenkins instancing you can see here
there's a lot of jobs starting with
meetup downloader so those will nicely
on particular days of the week do a full
run of this job that grabs all the data
for a particular City then obviously
just thinking Phil for for many reasons
although rate-limiting hasn't been one
of them yet because it turns out the
meetup API is so slow that if you don't
hit it with any parallelism you never
hit the rate limiting this is probably
also y de San Francisco job take 19
hours because the data set that comes
out of it is on the order of 4 and a
half gigabytes so that shouldn't take 19
hours but hey other things happen you
get broken connections every now and
then you get a you get a server error
and these kind of things so what I did
in the end this created job the
basically keeps track keeps a list of
all of the URLs that still needs to hit
in a little secret light database and
then it's just resumable so you can it
can break and then we could just restart
it and it'll pick up where it left off
and then also the JSON blob that it gets
out of it will go into sequel light as
well in that just a little local
database probably I could have done this
with scrappy as well but I had already
started on doing a little resting myself
so finish that so that basically gives
me a sequel I'd database with all the
downloaded Jason blobs for all of these
meetup activity in these big cities or
these texts cities
which is nice because it's a full data
set but obviously it isn't very
convenient for many purposes because
well I have Jason blobs in a database
without indexes or anything else so when
I when I was thinking about the domain
of the problem obviously it initially it
always makes sense to just think okay
I'll do this in my sequel or postgres or
something like that because I can query
nicely with sequel but if you if you
really think about the meetups it is
inherently network structure so instead
of doing a relational database I used a
graph database to store it its data
which actually gives you a lot of
interesting opportunities so the graph
database that I use is neo4j it's
there's a community of edition which is
open source and there's an enterprise
edition which can do additional things
but in the end it will store a graph and
provide you with a nice API and also
query language for it so neo4j stores
what we call property graphs that means
on the vertices and on the edges of the
graph you can store properties as well
and then you can also use those
properties when querying which is which
is very nice there's excellent pies and
support through a package called PI 2
neo and there is a query language which
is called cipher which basically is like
using ASCII art to describe what you
want so you can do things like give me
me which is a member by the name like
that so that's basically in the next
look up and then well just return that
and that should give me something but
not me
you guys are awake thank you so this
gave me a lot of means because I I
obviously ran these jobs for four
different cities so I'm in there a
couple of times so I can also do this
predicate where there should be this
additional Amsterdam label on me and
then it will give me just me right here
and I'm stabbed this is the the
graphical view and you can also get the
view in terms of rows where you just say
you know for each node and the
properties that are in there so this is
nice and you can do things like this for
example where I say okay I am me a
member and then there is a venue out
there somewhere and basically give me
the shortest path between me and a venue
for which this predicate applies the
city is damn boss which is somewhere in
the south of the Netherlands and then
when you run that query it's going to
take a while but in the end it will it
will basically come up with this where
me is right here so that's that's me and
then this is a venue in doubles this is
venue in doubles and this is one and it
gives me the shortest paths to to each
of them which is kind of nice because
you can do do quick explorations that
way this is what we call my ego network
so this is basically give me anything
connected to me through a relation
called RSVP to an event which organised
by some group so that's a query that
spans multiple vertices and edges and it
will give anything that matches that
which is the network of me and all of
the meetup events that I ever went to
including the groups that organize them
so this is nice and also nice is the
fact that you can also do these kinds of
queries where instead of returning
vertices and edges you can return
individual fields like names or
properties of nodes and edges and also
aggregates like counts so that basically
means instead of getting a graph back
you get just tabular data back so it's
it's a nice
way of getting the graph data in a
tabular form back to you and then of
course there's Python integration
through something called pi Tonio which
allows you to create this graph object
that accesses the graph database through
rest and then you can do something like
what's the database size and it'll get
you a number back right here so there's
about 2.6 million things in my database
you can query oh that looks horrible if
you have the notebook in the normal
screen it will actually nicely align and
be a little table so here we basically
get the last 10 events that I went to
and then PI tinea will give you that
back in some kind of character
representation if you represent it but
then the result set actually has some
some more interesting properties so the
result object is iterable and then also
its list like so it's fully materialized
see you can do things like get me the
last element and then the records within
the results that are also a dictionary
like but there are also objects as you
see on top where I just use the object
notation because you can also get them
through a dictionary notation especially
for Elias a--'s that have spaces in them
and other things that wouldn't be
normally expressible in in the Python
language and then it's pretty trivial to
construct and that's data frame out of
this so what i'm doing here is using the
fact that the result set is a durable
and just feed that to the data stream
data frame constructor there possibly
renaming the columns and then all of
sudden i'm in panels world which is nice
for a couple of things and we'll look at
that later and then there's this ipython
cipher package which helps you with a
couple of nice things first of all you
can do in line cipher queries using a
magic and then assign that to some kind
of result and the nice thing about the
result object that you get from this I
Python cipher package is that the
representation is a lot nicer this way
so that it has this get data frame
function that will ya return your data
frame so you're more easily in into
pandas them and then there's a level
magick for just putting a query there
and viewing the results in your notebook
so now that we have this set up there's
a couple of things that we can trivially
do so for example when I'm organizing a
meet up every now and then I'm sometimes
need to look for a venue and one of the
easiest things to do then especially if
the group is pretty substantial in size
is basically say okay give me all of the
venues and Amsterdam that ever hosted
anything before and sort them by some
kind of median event size and and tell
me which are which are the groups that
they've hosted so then what you get is
this this entire list of venues and I
can see the median event size that
happened there and the groups that were
ever hosted at that venue so this is
really convenient for me so I can just
send out a bunch of emails to two venues
that are probably in a market for
hosting one of the data meetups so
that's nice really convenient so you can
do things like this where you basically
say okay I run a query that will give me
the size of each of the meetup groups
and then I put that in a data frame and
then subsequently I just do a histogram
like this and it will tell me most of
the meetup groups are pretty small and
then there's a couple of larger ones and
that there is a lot of like these power
distributions in there which are to be
expected so one other thing that I i
think is interesting to look at is the
the overlap between different meetup
groups it basically tells you something
about how alike are these two audiences
when I was overlap it's really hard to
not think about fan diagrams and luckily
there's a package that creates Venn
diagrams and matte lip it's really nice
they can do a Venn diagram out of two or
three sets and you just feed it a number
of sets so we define this little
function here
year that does a cipher query gets the
member sets for a couple of meetup
groups and then feeds that to this Venn
diagram function and it can do this so
we have here the PI data Edelman's and
the UM star dumb meetup group what's the
hyphens there and other things which may
or may not be a reference to well the
syntax language but it's quite obvious
that there's a bit of overlap the our
meetup group is larger because it's been
around longer and it was to be expected
that there was no overlap there and you
can do the same with the graph database
group in the Netherlands and then you
get this nice diagram of the different
number of co-occurrences in those member
sets and then we can do something like
this where you see that there's you know
the r and the the graph database and the
PI data groups have have a bunch of
overlap in the graph database and this
Coco hats which is a mobile app
development group also has some overlap
but PI data doesn't have overlap with
Coco hats so the sort of might imply
that there's like two different
communities out there that do have some
form of common interest but not entirely
or not enough to be a community and then
obviously there's also completely
disjoint things which is kind of
disturbing because you know out of the
the data community right here in the
Netherlands absolutely zero are part of
the a light group of tomorrow's IT
leaders so obviously i immediately try
to fix this by signing up for tomorrow's
IT leaders meetup group but it turns out
they have to let you in and so it's a
work in progress i'll keep you posted
but this does quite clearly imply
combined with with these kind of things
that are quite likely communities within
these network within his networks so
that that leads us to to the next topic
where we start taking a bit of a closer
look at the network what i've used for
that is a package called i graph i graph
is available in python and our it's a
sea library
bindings in impulse it's not entirely
ready for python 3 yet but there are
some trivial fixes that he can do and i
got the pr accepted it's probably in an
upcoming release it will all be fixed
otherwise if you install it right now
through paper in Python 3 the plotting
is broken but then again mostly you use
byte in 27 anyway right i graph a
grafter that is library for you know
working with graphs it can do some graph
global things and also do calculations
on individual vertices like as between
us and centrality and these kind of
things and then also there's algorithms
for traversal but also community
detection which is the thing that we're
interested in here so this is again my
my ego network but then created as a
digraph object and I'm plotted in a
notebook so this is just this is mapped
or clip it actually generates an SVG you
can see your I'm there in the center all
the scien verses are events that don't
have names on them and the green things
are groups so their meetup groups so the
so this is basically my surrounding in
terms of the meetup graph and then when
I expand that by putting like two
members in there you can already see
that given to members there's sometimes
some commonality but there's also
particular groups that are completely
disjoint given these two members and
then when you go on like that and you
add people then obviously you kind of
see these parts in the graph where you
have different densities so instead of
actually having a look at that which is
fairly hard to visualize and also
doesn't really tell you low meaningful
things we're just going to let an
algorithm decide these are communities
and these are in and then from that
point on will look into those
communities and see whether it makes
sense so what I did is basically take
all the meetup groups in amsterdam and
relate them relate the members to those
groups through the events that those
members went to and then the the edge
weight of an act between a group and a
member is determined by how active that
member is in that group with some decay
over time so if I am active in a group
more recently that means more than I
used to go there a year ago or something
there's a couple of biases in here
because you know sometimes groups just
sees activity in general so that nobody
is active anymore and there's a couple
of other effects that are pretty hard to
take into account but generally this
gives us interesting results already so
we run the community detection and I
graph so this is basically what we do
here we say give me everybody in
allostatic greater amsterdam area that
and then all the activity that was prior
to january first of this year this is
also to account for the fact that
there's quite some seasonality in the
mid of event data and then the data
frame that comes out of that is
basically a group a member and then a
timestamp and recency so we need to
transform that into a group a member and
something that's at that particular
weight and then from there on we need to
construct a graph out of basically this
list of edges and now an i graph that's
pretty trivial actually create a graph
through something they call it tuple
list and what I do here the graph
relations is just the data frame so
that's the one you see here that has
these three columns and I basically tell
the values of that data frame is a list
of tuples with weights and boom you have
a graph and then we can run community
detection on that so the community
detection I graph has a lot of different
algorithms most of them are not very
scalable but the
the one that you would primarily use on
larger graph is an iterative method of
community detection which also will
actually return you a hierarchy of
communities if you like I think it's
cool I'm actually not sure I hear a
community multi-level the implementation
as far as I'm aware is actually an
implementation of what is better known
as the Louvre an algorithm which is a
Grady method for for optimizing network
modularity so it returns you all of the
different levels and then the last level
of that is the most coarse-grained so
maybe the first level it will detect
like 300 communities and then maybe 100
and then the last level is what you
actually get and that's 46 so this is
nice because we just went back from from
like 700 or 800 I think I think 900
meetup groups by now to only 46
communities that that share some
commonality and interest huge it
probably because the network was
constructed by attaching people to
groups based on their activity within
that group so some communities are
victims some are small these are all the
different communities that are detected
so 0 2 45 which is 46 and these are the
sizes of that community of each of the
community so you can see the largest one
over there slightly over 3,000 and the
smallest one is somewhere well quite
close to zero so there's there's a
couple of perhaps a noisy kind of
members in the network that don't really
add to to an FTM or more global picture
and when you look at the size
distribution it looks a lot like this so
most of the communities are are
somewhere between the around 500 and
then there's a couple of larger ones so
what we did next is try and establish a
rank so basically we're going to say so
what is the more important community out
of out of these the way we did that is
basically take this community detection
that we ran in I graph and then put the
results back into
the Neo database so then subsequently
becomes really easy to just query things
based on the community that they were
part of and then for each community what
you say okay so what a top 10 meetup
groups that play a role within this
community and from those will say okay
what is the activity amongst those
meetup groups for that community and
that that that basically gives us an
activity rank and then we'll say so in
2015 this was the most active community
within the Amsterdam texting and we have
that we have that rank and you have
those top end groups for each of the
communities you can finally start to
look at something and a week and it can
also compare these different cities so
this is Amsterdam and we're not doing
the top 10 here but it's only the top
three so you can see the community
number on the left which is signed by by
the algorithm and then the rank on the
right to basically says so this is the
number one meetup group in that
community and so the community numbers
obviously don't mean anything which is
arbitrarily assigned but the rank does
mean anything and what you can already
see here is that there there is you know
on the surface of it some commonality
between the groups that go in a
community so you can see it in Amsterdam
this whole startup and innovation thing
is really big and then secondly there's
like the develops crowd and then on the
third place alas there is the big data
and data science and then you know
moving on front end general web
development Internet of Things and smart
smart cities and these kind of things
and then here is PHP and other general
development so when we take answer them
and we compare this to Berlin you can
already see that there's there's
commonalities but there's also some
differences so for example in Berlin the
microservices is actually a thing and
then second second community there is
pretty much the big data data science so
perhaps in that sense they're ahead of
us and then William Berlin also not yet
is actually thing but that's also more
like
also for development great general web
development no chess meteor which is I
think in a PHP CMS or something no it's
not as our makes sense okay so that
that's all JavaScript then and then
there's a geek girls and an open tech
and that's interesting because what we
don't have that in Amsterdam I'm not
sure about the D open tech but we don't
have you know meetups specifically
targeted at getting women to code that
are also the most active ones I mean
they're there but they don't surface
into the top 10 but if you go on to
let's say not London but San Francisco
you see there the women who code is a
larger community that hack actually has
several meetup groups focusing on just
that and also over time they've already
went down in the top ten a bit so that
basically means that on the technology
side in Amsterdam we're not doing too
horribly although the big data and data
science is only in third place so we
need to work on that a little bit but
for the rest there's like these these
other kinds of movements that for some
reason we completely don't take part at
so shame on you Amsterdam but perhaps
it's just a matter of you know getting
the activity count up so the service is
interesting we basically get an idea of
the different sub communities within the
tech scene in these different cities and
then what else can we do so we haven't
looked at the contents of these events
yet and the command and what these
groups are made up of but it turns out
on meetup all of the groups actually a
group creation specify a number of
topics that will that supposedly
interest the people who become a member
of that group and then from their own
obviously a group will at some point
start organizing events and those have
descriptions and there's a lot of
textual textual data that we could could
have a look at as well
so what we aim to do them is basically
try and come up with a an unsupervised
and automated way of building you know a
global picture of what what these
communities and what these meetups are
about that let's sail a man or IT
managers as we call them can use to
figure out you know what's happening in
in this pool of people that they're so
desperately trying to hire from but
don't have a clue what these people do
on those now Thursday evenings in in a
room somewhere with their pizzas and
beers so in the end that's that's what
we're trying to achieve here so these
topics they're there they're pretty
static or if you create a meetup group
maybe some years ago and back then I
don't know MapReduce was the greatest
thing so so that became a topic of your
group but then over time you know the
world changed but the topic stay the
same but the event descriptions are a
lot more dynamic so they will pick up on
all these new topics for related phrases
so the big idea here is to yet basically
use this these topics to determine what
a group is about but then link those
topics two words and phrases that are in
the event descriptions which are more
dynamic and will reflect more or less
him modern or more recent trends in the
community and then we try and link all
that together to create one big network
visualization because that will also be
able to show you four different
communities what are let's say the
topics in between that linked them
together but not strongly enough to make
them a joint community I think perhaps
before we get to the implementation just
to kick you an idea what that looks like
so we figured hey we can use all this
data to create a technology radar one of
the marketing people is going to come up
with a better name but this is just my
prototype look has a nice picture of
Amsterdam there's communities in here
you can see the activity charts for each
of the communities and then for each of
the communities you can see which are
there
important groups who are the important
people and then what is the activity
within there and then finally this is
like the big idea of these communities
link to their topics and then linked to
whatever day they care about that's not
readable but you can see that for here
there's PHP web development and an
in-depth facility there's PHP stuff but
if you look at that's a big data that
assigns over here and functional
programming and scalable systems over
here and the thing that they have in
between there is like no sequel and
Hadoop and Cassandra which is kind of
interesting I don't know how flask came
up there we're working on that so so
what we do is we take all of the event
descriptions that are in English because
English is easy we're lazy so we have to
start somewhere there's a passing
package called lanky text which does
that really nicely especially on longer
texts like like event descriptions it's
extremely slow so it's written in pure
python and and it works on on character
trigram distributions so it has to do
all of the the classifications based on
that so so we trivially paralyzed that
on a local machine using apache spark
and then we strip HTML using beautiful
soup I think most of you will have heard
of that and then we run a Jensen's
excellent implementation of work to Veck
on that which I think right now is kind
of the state of the art in easily
accessible text representation local
parallelism would spark a little bit of
sidestep you can you can run apache
spark on your local machine but just
farming pi spark and then where it says
local and then between the brackets it
says eight that means it will take eight
cores and that's it so that will give
you a local runner of spark using eight
cores and then
what we do in spark is basically say
okay I'm going to create a parallelized
data set out of all of the group IDs
that I have in the database so that's
the local operation and I and then I
push that into a parallel data structure
and then from there on and you're going
to say ok so now I can do a let's say
absurdo distributed operation so it's
going to be distributed across those
eight course where I say ok so each of
these spark process is going to take a
part of the data and actually fetch
those groups from the database so this
will create parallelism against the
database which of course has to be able
to handle but then if in the end the
goal is to parallel eyes this one very
slow pure python package this works very
nicely it was realized that that
especially from Python spark has quite a
lot of overhead so so for for general
like I l-band kind of things it's
probably better to just stick with local
but in these particular situations this
works quite nicely and then on the
resulting event descriptions we actually
don't do a lot of pre-processing at this
point so some still working a bit on the
on the text stuff doing a bit of
pre-processing doing trying to to
actually clean up a couple of the nasty
things like hash tags and URLs and this
kind of thing right now we actually
don't do any of that and already it can
do things like this saying hey what's
similar to machine learning I will come
up with computer vision and statistical
modeling and deep learning and data
mining but also for iOS it will know
Android and Windows Phone an iphone and
mobile so that that's pretty nice and
it's a pretty useful model for further
thing that we want to create and then in
the visualization we basically connect
communities to the topics that are
prevalent in the groups of that
community and then we rerun tf-idf over
that because a lot of these groups have
an interest in computer programming but
yeah and then from those topics well
that actually doesn't fit
let me see you again no it does so from
those topics we recursively look at the
similar terms of to a particular
threshold so the termination criteria as
basically the similarity should be above
some number and that for each iteration
in the recursion we decay that with a
little bit and at some point it just
stops and then yeah the final result is
this which I've just shown you this this
network of communities and topics and
related terms initially it would perform
pretty poorly but we fix that by
grabbing more data from the API hence
Chicago is in there and I think that's
it perhaps we have some question time if
there are any